quand on fait les courses quand on a une
famille nombreuse vous avez 9 enfants et
ils sont tous à la maison ou pas non
plus maintenant alors il nous en reste
que quatre maintenant ah ça va ouais
ouais comment on fait les courses quand
on est une famille nombreuse comment on
fait bah on va au magasin
[Rires]
c'est vraiment le plus gros budget c'est
nous quand il y avait plusieurs enfants
quand il y avait 7 enfants on mettait
jusqu'à 1200 € de course par mois
c'est énorme en plus les parents parce
que on dit les enfants mais il y a les
parents aussi qui mangent beaucoup mais
vraiment le le truc fou de des familles
nombreuses c'est ah ouais c'est le
panier de course est-ce qu'il a augmenté
parce que là maintenant vous avez encore
quatre enfants c'est ce que c'est c'est
parce que ce que vous vous sentez
vraiment une augmentation alors
franchement on le ressent maintenant la
des ces jours-là qui viennent on le
ressent on était à 700 entre 700 et 800
maintenant on monte presque jusqu'à 1000
euros